bonjour à tous et bien ça y est c'est le
dernier cours de l'été c'est la fin de
la saga de l'été avec cet ultime cours
sur l'évolution des invertébrés
alors je rappel contrairement à toutes
les autres vidéos que j'ai pu faire
c'est une
c'est un cours qui s'adressent aux
premières années de géologie donc on va
rester très très basique on va rester
vraiment à la surface on va pas vraiment
exploré toute la grande histoire
évolutive des invertébrés en seulement
une heure on va vraiment juste car et
s'est gentiment la surface déjà vous
allez voir que ça fait pas mal de
contenu ça fait déjà pas mal de mots
nouveaux aussi notamment si vous pensez
au niveau première année de licence ça
fait déjà beaucoup de choses nouvelles à
apprendre mais mais on va quand même ça
va nous occuper un bon moment vous allez
voir ça va déjà nous apprendre pas mal
de choses mais c'est du niveau première
année donc contrairement au reste qui
était du niveau master ça va être
beaucoup moins développés évidemment je
n'ai pas la prétention de couvrir toute
l'évolution des invertébrés et tout leur
classification c'est une histoire
gigantesque formidable que je ne
prétends même pas moi même connaître
réellement dans que donc on va rester
assez superficiel mais néanmoins on voit
quand même voir les bases de quels sont
les groupes d'invertébrés important dans
un contexte encore une fois africain et
sud-africain et quels sont les groupes
aussi de paix et comment on utilise
surtout ces invertébrés à des fins de
reconstruction paléoenvironnementales et
à des fins de à des fins de datation
aussi puisque nous avions beaucoup
insisté la dernière fois sur
l'importance des fossiles pour dater les
roches et on avait beaucoup insisté
aussi sur l'importance des fossiles en
terme de reconstruction
paléoenvironnementales j'avais pas donné
beaucoup d'exemples mais justement ça va
être l'occasion de voir des exemples
plus concrets de comme en utilisent les
fossiles comment commander notamment des
compagnies industrielles et minières
peuvent utiliser des fossiles
évidemment on va aussi étudier l'origine
et l'évolution de désinfecter bray en
même temps qu'on étudie leur intérêt
scientifique stratigraphique et c'est
donc donc on va commencer bien
évidemment par le début à savoir
l'origine de la vie et dans un contexte
africain la chose qu'on ne peut pas
esquiver on va dire c'est le lait
stromatolithes puisque nous avons
beaucoup beaucoup de stromatolithes en
afrique du sud et notamment dans la
région de johannesburg
plus tôt dans la région de pretoria
d'ailleurs qui se trouve un peu plus au
nord de johannesbourg ouh là là
évidemment on a beaucoup beaucoup de
stromatolithes qui ont plusieurs
milliards d'années
donc ils font pas ce qu'ils font partie
des fossiles les plus vieux du monde qui
ne sont dont l'âge finalement né nenê
n'est égalée que par des fossiles qu'on
retrouve au canada et en australie
donc c'est stromatolithes la terre c'est
fort mais il y a 4 5 milliards d'années
environ
et les premières traces de vie sont
d'environ 4 milliards d'années avec plus
ou moins de millions d'années de 200
millions d'années de débats entre autour
de 4 milliards d'années
mais en gros les les premiers
stromatolithes sûr qu'on a
ils ont 3 8 milliards d'années est ce
qu'on trouve en amérique en afrique du
sud
ils ont 3,5 milliards d'années et on en
retrouve jusqu'à 2 5 milliards d'années
donc ceux qui se trouvent à pretoria
sont les plus jeunes ils ont environ 2,7
milliards d'années qui sont parmi les
plus jeunes et sains et après quand on
monte jusqu'à la frontière avec le
swaziland
là on va dans la formation qui s'appelle
la barre burton et à barberton on a des
stromatolites qui ont 3,5 milliards
d'années et là on a certains d'entre eux
qui ont donné les plus anciennes traces
de vie connue les traces d'organismes
unicellulaires puisque c'est ce et de la
préservation enchères tu donc en silex
et à l'intérieur de silex on peut faire
des sections fine et là on peut voir les
petites cellules entre les couches de
stromatolithes donc c'est vraiment des
très très très beau fossile donc c'est
stromatolithes ce sont des tapis de
terry en fait qui se sont qui ont déposé
derrière eux une couche de calcite et
donc ces tapis bactérien il commence sur
une petite surface donc vous avez un
petit tapis bactérien qui forment une
couche de calcite une nouvelle un
nouveau tapis bactérien qui se forment
au dessus qui a un petit peu plus grands
qui forment une nouvelle couche de
calcite et ainsi de suite ce qui donne
au final ses formes en champignons à ses
caractéristiques des troubles des
stromatolites tous les stromatolithes
non pas une jolie forme en champignons
comme ça parce que comme vous pouvez le
comprendre
déjà parce que je vous dise tout part
d'un tapis bactérien donc la forme est
totalement aléatoire mais voilà
généralement on a une belle forme en
champignons sur ces tapis bactérienne
mais vous pouvez voir ici que ça peut
avoir des formes très variées c'est
stromatolithes et ce qui est important
c'est surtout pas cette l'itii fication
set li ti fication en cas en carbonate
de calcium qui est très typique des
stromatolites alors là c'est il s'agit
des stromatolites de la région de
pretoria qui ont été certifiés donc qui
ont été silicifiées on va dire donc là
on a plus de carbonate de calcium dansez
dansez stromatolithes là mais ce sont
des finalement c'est la pétrification
des restes laissés par une trace
d'activité d'organismes voilà c'est ça
les stromatolithes c'est la
pétrification d'une trace d'activité
d'organismes donc au final c'est même
pas un vrai faux cils c'est une trace
fossiles enfin c'est pas un fossile de
remplacement voilà je vais pas appeler
ça fout fossiles surtout pas que je
fasse ça se sont pas des traces de
directement de du corps du fossile qui a
été remplacé mais bel et bien la trace
de l'activité de ce fossile de
l'activité de ces cyanobactéries donc
les cyanobactéries c'est les premiers
organismes pour lesquelles on a
réellement un registre fossile et on
voit toujours des cyanobactéries
aujourd'hui donc là par exemple bah
c'est le fameux exemple de shark bay en
australie où vous avez des très très
beau stromatolithes qui nous indique
d'ailleurs que les stromatolithes sont
des organismes qui vivent en eau peu
profonde
ils ont besoin de la lumière du soleil
donc c'est pareil ça nous indique aussi
le paléoenvironnement qu'il y avait ici
même au tour de johannesbourg et
pretoria
il y a des milliards d'années c'est à
dire qu'on peut s'imaginer qu'il ya des
milliards d'années le ressembler à ça
alors fait intéressant il semblerait que
ces stromatolithes ça a été découvert
assez récemment il semblerait que ce
stromatolithes enfin que les
cyanobactéries de l'époque utiliser un
pigment violet est pas un pigment bleu
comme elles le font aujourd'hui enfin
bleu vert comme elles le font
aujourd'hui
et ça c'est vachement intéressant ça
veut dire que les océans était pourpre à
l'époque c'est ce devait être super cool
la planète entière ça se trouve il y
avait quasiment que des cyanobactéries à
l'époque et des petits machins qui
mangent et d'autres petites bactéries
qui mangeaient les cyanobactéries
donc en gros ça veut dire que le monde
devait être recouverte d'océans
complètement complètement violet
ça devait être assez ouf ce qui
s'accorderait relativement bien
d'ailleurs avec les rayonnements du
soleil alors après je suis pas physicien
donc je sais pas comment on se sait où
comment on peut savoir quels genres de
rayonnement faisait le soleil il ya 4
milliards d'années le soleil jeune mais
il semblerait que le soleil jeunes
avaient un rayonnement qui s'accordent
relativement bien avec le fait que les
bactéries et développer un pigment
pourpre pour l'absorber
donc je vois là c'est ce que j'ai lu je
vous le donne je vous le mets là je vous
mets là mais je ne peux pas je peux pas
dire si c'est vrai ou faux pour le coup
l'une étant j'y connais quasiment rien
au physique
s'il ya des physiciens qui regarde s'il
vous plaît vos explications je suis
totalement ouvert à la contradiction de
ce point de vue là
et on a aussi les premières traces
d'oxygénation de l'atmosphère
donc évidemment les cyanobactéries sont
des organismes qui sont
photosynthétiques dons qu'ils utilisent
le co2 et recrache de l'o2 comme déchets
donc de l'oxygène comme déchets et tout
ça ils s'en servent ou pour faire du du
sucre de l'énergie physiologique quoi
donc
donc on a aussi les premières traces
d'oxygénation et ses premières traces
d'oxygénation elles sont aussi préservée
dans l'est dans la région de barberton
puisque vous avez des cous de des
couches de chair tu donc encore une fois
de silex qui on est et qui préserve ses
traces en fait d'oxydation puisque
l'océan va se charger en oxygène mais
l'océan il est riche en fer à l'époque
et se faire du couvent à s'oxyder forme
et de la rouille et s'être où il va
précipiter et donc là ce que vous voyez
passer les couches qu'on appelle le de
fer rubané et se faire re ba néo voyez
il ya du fer oxydé du fer réduit donc
plutôt verdâtre rue du fer oxydé rue du
fer réduire du fer oxydé parce que vous
avez des cycles en fait de sueur
oxygénation en fait de l'océan donc donc
c'est cyclique en fait il ya des
relargages d'oxygène qui sont cycliques
à chaque fois que l'océan fini saturé
par l'oxygène et bien le faire s'oxyde
précipite donc le séant n'est plus
saturée en oxygène donc les bactéries
reproduisent de l'oxygène re sature
l'océan bond sarr précipite mais l'océan
n'est plus saturés etc
et c'est donc là ce qu'on voit encore
une fois c'est pas un fossile mais ce
sont des traces fossiles de l'activité
de l'oxygénation de l'océan et cette
oxygénation de l'océan elle est capitale
dans l'évolution de la vie puisque quand
les océans vont finir par être
complètement saturée en oxygène cet
oxygène va être relarguer après dans
l'atmosphère et quand est mosphere va
être complètement largués en
complètement saturée en oxygène donc à
peu près au niveau où on en est
aujourd'hui d'oxygène est bien là et
bien là en fait ça va devenir la merde
parce que les organismes jusqu'à présent
et là on est à peu près à deux milliards
d'années quand ça se produit quand le
monde est saturé d'oxygène donc il ya
deux milliards d'années en gros les
organismes ils vivent dans un monde qui
est saturé d'une cochonneries qui
flingue l'oxygène est un déchet à
l'époque
l'oxygène est un déchet le dioxygène
évidemment lot 2 est un déchet c'est un
déchets métaboliques
donc ça les tuent des animaux est
d'ailleurs le l'oxygène est un occident
l'occident il ya détruit tout non pas
seulement les bombes des américains blog
dans le les oxydants allez donc
l'oxygène dit le dioxygène typiquement
ça détruit tous et notamment ce qui est
biologique le feu s'est de l'oxydé c'est
une réaction d'oxydation la rouille est
une réaction d'oxydation ça détruit pas
seulement le biologique ça détruit aussi
le les métaux donc l'oxydation c'est
quelque chose qui est très dangereux et
c'était à partir de ces pendant cette
période justement où les couches de fer
rubané vont s'accumuler que les
organismes petit à petit s'adapter à la
saturation d'oxygène jusqu'à ce qu'il y
à deux milliards d'années
il n'est plus le choix que de survivre
avec l'oxygène donc on a pas de traces
fossiles de ça mais aujourd'hui tous les
organismes qui vivent à la surface de la
terre après je parle pas des trucs qui
vivent dans des environnements extrêmes
mais tous les organismes qui vivent
aujourd'hui à la surface de la terre
sont des descendants de ces organismes
qui se sont adaptés à l'oxygène à tel
point qu'aujourd'hui on imagine plus la
vie sans oxygène
mais faut vous imaginer que pendant 2
milliards d'années donc plus de la
moitié à peu près la moitié de
l'existence de la vie sur terre
l'oxygène et est un déchet et pas autre
chose aujourd'hui c'est une condition
nécessaire à la vie mais à l'époque
c'était un déchet donc voilà et aussi
pour dire quelle occase l'être humain ce
n'est pas le premier à flinguer son
environnement au point de le polluer
jusqu'à saturation mais bon ça c'est un
c'est une autre discussion
les cyanobactéries ont fait ça bien
avant nous donc il y à deux milliards
d'années
l'oxygène il y en a partout et qu'est ce
qui se passe bien les organismes vont
commencer à pouvoir se bouffer entre eux
parce que en utilisant cet oxygène en
s'adaptant à cette présence d'oxygène
ils vont aussi apprendre à l'utiliser et
quand on utilise l'oxygène de la deûle
environnement pour bousiller son petit
voisin d'à côté pour pouvoir grignoter
ce qui se trouve à l'intérieur
et bah ça s'appelle ça s'appelle la
respiration en fait c'est la respiration
d'un point de vue physiologique en fait
la respiration d'un point de vue
physiologique c'est absorbé de
l'atmosphère pour briser des pour briser
des nutriments et donc ça c'est que
c'est une conséquence directe de cette
saturation en oxygène des organismes
apprennent à se servir de cet oxygène
pour briser d'autres organismes et se
nourrir de ce qu'il ya à l'intérieur
c'est la naissance de la prédation
c'est la naissance du coût des systèmes
de défense contre la prédation l'un
d'entre eux étant on propose du moins on
suppose on y peut on fait l'hypothèse
l'un de ces moyens de protection étant
la multi cellular é tait et on trouve
ses premières traces d'organismes
multicellulaires il y à 2,2 milliards
d'années à 2,1 milliards d'années
environ
donc et en afrique pour l'instant en
afrique exclusivement donc au gabon du
côté de franceville on a le fameux
biotope de franceville lien qui a été
découvert par un chercheur de poitiers
justement donc
cocorico et donc ce biotope de
franceville il est fait d'animaux qui
sont même pas symétriques pas
particulièrement symétrique on sait même
pas si c'est des animaux d'ailleurs
jeudi des animaux mais dans ces
organismes
on sait pas si c'est des animaux des
végétaux certains proposent que ce sont
juste des colonies bactériennes mai
a pas l'air du tout d'être des
ressemblent pas des colonies
bactériennes la signature isotopique a
pas l'air non plus de coller mais bon on
sait pas on sait pas exactement ce que
c'est mais en tout cas c'est les
premiers jeux multicellulaires c'est la
première fois qu'on voit des organismes
vivre de façon multicellulaires donc ça
c'est à 2 milliards d'années aussi au
gabon on retrouve enfin 2 milliards 1 à
2 milliards d'années on retrouve aussi
au gabon les premières traces de
terriers alors qui dit terrier divers
donc il y avait il y avait des organisme
vermiforme on n'en a pas les traces
fossiles on n'a pas les fossiles direct
mais on en a les traces fossiles pareil
en afrique du sud on retrouve aussi des
traces de verre qu'on appelle des bio
turba sion d'ailleurs donc on retrouve
de tels bio turba sion aussi en afrique
et en afrique du sud et en afrique du
sud on retrouve aussi cette espèce de
machin qui en forme de coupe entre en
forme de vers quoi qui s'appelle 10k
gamins et on suppose que c'était aussi
un organisme bien que ça ressemble pas
grand chose mais on suppose que c'était
un organismes multicellulaires donc tout
ça nous montre qu'il ya 2,2 milliards
d'années c'est le début de la vie
multicellulaire c'est le début de la de
la vie qui s'est adapté à manger de la
vie qui a appris à s'en défendre et du
coup les prédateurs sa apprennent à
contourner ces défenses en devenant eux
mêmes multicellulaires en devenant plus
gros etc etc
donc voilà comment la vie est devenue
multicellulaires par la saturation de
l'oxygène en oxygène du aux
cyanobactéries donc tout ça ça a pris
très longtemps vous voyez pour l'instant
l'évolution est très lente
et puis donc donc là pour l'instant
j'appelle pas enfin si on va appeler ces
organismes entre guillemets des
métazoaires parce qu'elles sont faites
plusieurs cellules mais c'est pas sûr du
tout d'ailleurs que ces organismes soit
des vrais métazoaires bon maintenant les
vrais métazoaires c'est à dire ceux pour
lequel on est sûr ça va être
essentiellement donc les éponges qu'on
appelle les ports y faire et les les
cnidaires donc ce qu'on pourrait appeler
les policiers enfin les méduses tout ça
les coraux donc les voilà des cnidaires
donc les métazoaires c'est l'ensemble
organismes à plusieurs cellules est le
premier groupe qu'on va voir donc c'est
les ports y faire ou éponge
donc c'est pour y faire ils ont une
organisation qui est très simple c'est
juste une cavité et des trous autour qui
filtre et le en fait là lors entre par
les petites roues est filtrée et ressort
par le gros trou qui a au sommet qui
s'appelle losc hull
donc c'est vraiment des organismes très
très simple les premières traces des
ponge qu'on connaisse viennent de
namibie et en huit cent mille ans donc
elles sont beaucoup plus jeunes que
l'origine hypothétique des éponges elles
mêmes qu'on se situe à peu près à 1
voire 2 milliards d'années cc des dates
qui sont donnés par datation moléculaire
par l'horloge moléculaire donc on compte
le nombre de comptes
le nombre de mutations qui lie à entre
les différentes espèces de pour y faire
et les espèces de cnidaires et on peut
dire que les deux groupes ont divergé il
ya entre un et deux milliards d'années
évidemment tout ça dépend beaucoup du
nombre de mutations du nombre de gènes
que vous incluez et de des points de
calibration que vous utilisez pour
pouvoir dater mais bref donc en tout cas
on sait qu'à huit cent mille ans est
beaucoup plus jeune que l'origine
supposée dépôt aurifère donc il ya
certainement un gros registre fossile
manquant pour ses ports y faire donc le
type d'organisation est très simple il
est d'autant plus simple qu'il n'y a que
deux couches embryonnaire de feuillets
embryonnaires l'hecto d'air mais l'hecto
derme et l'endoderme donc l'hecto derme
c'est la peau l'endoderme c'est le tube
digestif
voilà il n'y a rien entre les deux donc
ya pas d'os il n'y a pas de ya pas de
muscles il n'y a rien de voilà il ya
juste il ya juste de la peau et un tube
digestif dedans voilà il n'y a pas ce
qu'on appelle le met au derme là où on
trouve pour nous par exemple c'est là où
on va trouver les os et les muscles et
les certains organes ni rien d'autre que
voilà
donc l'écologie de ses ports y faire si
vous trouvez des fossiles de pori faire
leur écologie c'est essentiellement de
l'eau peu profonde et généralement
généralement chaude encore qu'on trouve
des espèces dans des eaux plutôt froide
d'ailleurs ce qui va se passer c'est que
dans les milieux de forte énergie donc
dans les milieux où il ya beaucoup de
remous vous allez trouver des formes qui
sont plutôt qu'ils sont plutôt prostré
des formes qui sont plutôt courtes
enfin des éponges qui sont plutôt
courtes et massive et plus on va aller
vers des milieux de faible énergie donc
des milieux qui sont qui sont moins où
il ya moins de remous donc par exemple
un lagon par exemple un petit lagon
tropical
voilà on va trouver des éponges qui ont
plein de ramifications et c'est donc
c'est un très très bon marqueur de
l'écologie notamment de l'énergie du
courant qui avait à l'époque dont juste
par le type de fossiles de dépenses que
vous pouvez que vous retrouverez vous
pouvez dire si le courant était fort ou
pas là où vous l'avez trouvé ça c'est
intéressant
et apparemment il semble aussi que les
formes de froide soit moins ramifié que
les formes dauchot donc vous pouvez
aussi avoir une idée de la température
de l'eau rien qu'en regardant la ramie
les ramifications de ces et pontonx et
des fossiles qui sont très intéressants
c'est quelque chose qui va marcher aussi
avec beaucoup d'autres invertébrés comme
on va le voir ce système des
ramifications égal moins d'énergie donc
maintenant on attaque les cnidaires donc
les cnidaires sont très similaires aux
éponges c'est pareil c'est juste de la
peau sur le dessus et un tube digestif à
l'intérieur mais la différence c'est que
les cnidaires ils sont un peu plus
organisés dans le sens où ils ont d axe
de symétrie on parle de symétrie radial
c'est à dire que au lieu d'avoir une
symétrie comme nous bilatérales c'est à
dire un axe de symétrie qui sépare la
gauche et la droite
eux ils vont avoir une
un centre de symétrie est donc le même
motif va se répéter de façon radial donc
différents cercles le même motif va se
répéter en cercle donc c'est un peu
mieux organiser qu'une éponge qui n'est
pas organisée du tout ce que vous voyez
là mais c'est pas c'est pas non plus une
symétrie bilatérales que ce qu'on va
voir chez les bills à therrien donc ccc
cnidaires ils sont généralement comme
les éponges ce sont des filtres heures
des organismes filtreurs qui vont plus
ou moins vivre de façon qu'ils vont plus
ou moins être dépendant aussi de de
cyanobactéries pour l'heure pour là
qu'ils vont faire de la photosynthèse
pourrait en fait ils vont être plus ou
moins dépendant d'une dune d'une
symbiose avec les cyanobactéries
notamment les coraux vont être dépendant
des cyanobactéries donc les coraux
encore une fois c'est des choses qu'on
va retrouver dans des eaux peu profondes
et tropicales parce que justement ils
ont cette symbiose avec les
cyanobactéries qui nécessite beaucoup de
lumière et on va les retrouver alors on
va avoir des riffs des des barrières de
corail dans les milieux tropicaux donc
là où il va y avoir beaucoup de
nutriments il va y avoir beaucoup de
beaucoup d'ensoleillement aussi des
températures qui permettent de croître
rapidement
donc ces barrières de corail on va les
retrouver plus tôt en milieu tropical
mais après on va trouver des formes plus
solitaire qu'on va retrouver dans les
formes de froide bas où il ya il peut y
avoir aussi des nutriments dans l'eau
froide mais le problème c'est que vu que
l'eau est froide ça ralentit le
métabolisme du coup ils grandissent
moins vite
donc ces coraux ils sont pas hyper hyper
intéressant du point de vue bio
stratigraphique donc ils sont très
intéressants du point de vue écologique
du point de vue stratigraphie qui sont
moins intéressants encore que on a une
distinction entre deux grands groupes de
coraux les hexacore à lierre et les
tetra chorale hier donc les hexa core à
lierre ça va être les coraux typique du
mésozoïque jusqu'à aujourd'hui donc
c'est encore les coraux qu'on retrouve
aujourd'hui et ceux là ont une symétrie
radial bien marquer donc vous pouvez
voir que la symétrie radial et
extrêmement régulière et on les retrouve
depuis le mésozoïque contrairement aux
tetra chorale hier où les rugueux comme
on les appelle en français
l'été sera chorale hier au rugueux eux
ils ont une symétrie une symétrie radial
qui est beaucoup plus altérée et qui est
quasiment une symétrie bilatérales
finalement vous pouvez voir que les
petits septum là que vous voyez à
l'intérieur ils sont pas du tout
organisé en cercle comme on peut le voir
sur cette hexa core allières ils sont
plutôt sont plutôt irrégulier alors
c'est évidemment c'est un caractère qui
c'est qui est pas
qui est pas absent fin qui n'est pas
sans aucune exception il ya certains
hexa core à lierre qui vont avoir une
symétrie quasiment bilatérales donc donc
faut faire très attention quand on
utilise du coup ce caractère là pour
savoir si on est en train de regarder
des roches du paléozoïque ou des roches
du mésozoïque ou du cénozoïque mais
disons que c'est un caractère général en
fait c'est être encore à lierse et
rugueux ils vont être quand même plutôt
caractéristiques oueds et des milieux
paléozoïque mais il faut faire très
attention si on n'est pas spécialiste si
on sait pas trop identifié les coraux
faut faire attention ne pas tirer des
conclusions trop hâtives parce que des
fois il y à des examens vallières qui
vont avoir un quasi axe de symétrie
bilatérales comme des êtres accord à
lire il faut faire très attention donc
un troisième grand groupe parmi ces
métazoaires et qui n'existe plus
aujourd'hui ce sont ce qu'on appelle les
organismes dédiés à kara donc ces
organismes dédia il était très très
diversifiés donc il est fort peu
probable
il est assez peu probable qu'ils forment
un groupe phylogénétiquement cohérent
mais ils ont tous cette particularité en
fait d'être préservée en deux dimensions
et d'avoir d'avoir l'air d'être des
organismes pneumatiques
bien que l'on ne sache pas vraiment de
quoi il en retourne en sais même pas
s'ils vivaient tous fixés ou non on sait
même pas si certains étaient des verts
et d'autres étaient plus des plantes
donc pour l'instant les appelle juste
voilà moi je les appelle juste des
organismes dédiés à kara juste pour
faire simple parce qu'il est fort
probable que certains de ces organismes
enfin que ces organismes entre eux ne
soient pas finalement relier directement
phylogénétiquement entre quoi donc leur
écologie on ne la connaît pas elle est
très diversifiée certainement comme j'ai
dit certains étaient certainement plus
des verts et d'autres étaient
certainement plus comme des plantes et
et on ne sait même pas s'il vivait
réellement fixé donc on n'est pas
vraiment sûr en gros deux niveaux
marquage écologique et
paléoenvironnementales ils sont pas
super intéressant ces organismes dédiés
à kara par contre ils sont très
intéressants du point de vue datation
parce qu'on ne les retrouve qu'entre 800
milles et 505 ont entre 800 et 550
millions d'années pardon
donc donc c'est une tranche de temps qui
est juste avant le début du cambrien et
on retrouve ces organismes du côté de du
côté de la namibie dans le sud de
l'afrique donc en namibie ils ont de
très jolis organisme dédié à kara dont
vous pouvez voir les photos ici donc
l'aller les exemples namibiens et ils
ont notamment ranger à qui est assez
assez commun en namibie
vous avez aussi des trous de terriers
vous avez aussi des claudine a qui sont
très communs
donc est ce qu'il ya d'intéressant avec
ces organismes dédiés à kara c'est que
contrairement aux organismes qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure dans le biotope france
villien là on a des bilatérales rien
c'est à dire qu'on a des organismes avec
une symétrie qui passe par le milieu du
corps avec une symétrie bilatérales donc
c'est la première trace en fait les
organismes dédiés à kara ce serait la
première trace mme d'organismes
bilatérales encore que à franceville
comme jédir on avait des verts qui
pourrait être du coup des bilatérales
mais bon on n'a pas encore trouvé le les
fossiles eux mêmes on n'a que les traces
s'ensuit ensuite l'explosion cambrienne
l'explosion cambrienne c'est un
événement marquant de la l'évolution de
la vie donc à ce moment là ça fait à peu
près 3 milliards et demi d'années que la
vie existe donc sachant que la terre à
3,5 milliards d'années c'est en gros la
plupart de l'histoire de la terre enfin
pendant la plupart de l'histoire de la
terre en gros la terre a été recouverte
d'un organisme relativement simple et
mou et tout gluant et elle allait
l'histoire évolutive a été relativement
lente aussi vous avez une apparition des
organismes pluricellulaires mais
globalement ça a mis 2 milliards
d'années à se produire et pendant 2
milliard d'années après on voit pas
grand chose se produire dans le registre
fossile c'est ce qui veut pas dire qu'il
s'est rien passé
mais on ne voit pas grand chose se
produire dans le registre fossile
on suppose que c'est là que tous les
grands groupes d'invertébrés sont
apparus mais on n'a pas de preuve
directe mais au début du cambrien on a
un pic d'oxygène donc encore une fois le
vous voyez que là le niveau d'oxygène
c'est ce que je vous parlais tout à
l'heure
le niveau où on allait les faire rubané
là c'est cette augmentation générale de
l'oxygène donc avec le grand événement
d'oxydation ici à 2000 yards autour de
deux milliards d'années
pardon de milliards d'années et l'a donc
un petit peu avant quand même des
milliards d'années trois milliards et
demi d'années ça culmine à 2 milliards
d'années on a des pointillés ici on sait
pas trop ce qui se passe mais d'une
façon ou d'une autre ça redescend et ça
remonte voilà et ça remonte au niveau
quasiment actuelle ici un avec une
grosse descente ici qui correspond à la
limite permise trias je suppose ou
peut-être au dévonien
je ne sais pas c'est toute façon c'est
pas sûr sac et que ce graphe focus ce
qu'il faut cus c'est vraiment le début
du fan héros zurich avec le niveau
d'oxygène qui d'un seul coup il remonte
au niveau quasiment actuel tel qu'il
était presque
il y à deux milliards d'années donc là
on a le niveau d'oxygène quasiment
actuelle et ça ça a lieu au début du
cambrien donc au début du cambrien on a
cette grande augmentation de l'oxygène
du niveau d'oxygène et c'est aussi là
qu'on voit apparaître ce qu'on appelle
les exosquelettes donc les coquilles
donc les exosquelettes d articuler des
arthropodes
c'est ça qui fait qu'on les appelle des
arthropodes et les exosquelettes côte il
y ait des mollusques par exemple c'est à
ce moment là que tout ça apparaît on
sait pas vraiment pourquoi ça a lieu on
sait pas vraiment pourquoi serre liés
aux taux d'oxygène
peut-être que ça ne l'est même pas
d'ailleurs mais en tout cas c'est là que
ça a lieu l'apparition de ces
exosquelette fait aussi que c'est
l'apparition des fossiles donc on a le
fan et re donc c'est pour ça et
d'ailleurs qu'on marque que sa marque le
début du fan et roseaux vite le fan et
rose os x et loïc les animaux fans héros
qui se voit fans héros donc c'est la vie
qui se voit en fait c'est l'époque de la
vie qui se voit contrairement aux pros
théosophique où la vie ne se voyait pas
où on a un fossile un registre fossile
qui est assez qui est qui est vrai vrai
vraiment très très parcellaire donc le
début du fan héroïque qui marque aussi
le début du cambrien c'est l'explosion
cambrienne qui est en fait un
finalement c'est juste un billet de
fossilisation puisque c'est juste que
avant la vie ne se fossilise est pas et
après la vie se fossilise parce qu'elle
a une coquille et des exosquelettes
voilà donc on sait d'après l'horloge
moléculaire qu'il ya des choses qui se
sont passées avant ça mais tout était
mou tout était tout était gluant et pas
grand chose se fossiliser à ce moment-là
parler des petits des petits instants
comme la vie en comme le veut la faune
dédia carats en namibie comme la faune
de enfin le biotope franceville ya voilà
on a des petites photos des snapshots
comme ça mais on n'a pas un bon registre
fossile comme après va se développer
durant deux femmes héroïques donc
l'explosion cambrienne c'est le début du
cambrien et le début du fan héroïque et
c'est là qu'on commence à trouver
beaucoup de faux cils donc en afrique du
sud
ça commence avec ce qu'on appelle la lah
les montagnes du cap donc et notamment
le groupe de la montagne de la table
donc si vous connaissez la montagne de
la table en afrique du sud vous que vous
êtes déjà allés visiter le cap et que
vous avez monté la montagne de la table
eh bien vous avez monté des sédiments
qui sont cambrien dans lesquels on
retrouve les premiers fossiles fans
héroïque d'afrique d'afrique du sud en
france on a on a des gisements cambrien
notamment du côté de du côté de la
bretagne je crois si je me rappelle bien
donc on retrouve aussi et on a aussi d
archéo siat qui viennent de du languedoc
donc nous sommes entrés dans le fan
héroïque voici la grande échelle du
l'échelle des temps géologiques du fan
héroïque qui commence avec le cambrien
et le paléozoïque donc nous sommes il ya
540 millions d'années quand nous entrons
dans l'âge des trilobites et de et nous
entendre surtout dans l'âge des
invertébrés
je vais pas couvrir la faune de burgès
tout simplement parce qu'on ne retrouve
pas d'exemple de la faune de burgès en
afrique de même qu on en retrouve pas
non plus en europe
on retrouve en fait il ya que deux
endroits où l'on retrouve de la faune de
burgès c'est à burges et à shenyang
donc c'est une faune qui est
complètement atypique à savoir qu'il ya
on y retrouve des choses qu'on ne
retrouvera quasiment pas après et qu'on
ne trouvait pas avant donc au final
c'est 100 sans dire que c'est
anecdotique
d'un point de vue strictement géologique
ça sert pas à grand chose puisque on
courait le rien vous vous rappelez de ce
que c'était qu'un bon fossiles
indicateurs un beauf aussi l'indicateur
c'est un fossile qui se trouve à plein
d'endroits qui est abondant et qui se
retrouvent enfin qui est surtout à plein
d'endroits et abondant et là pour le
coup on n'a que deux endroits et on n'en
retrouve pas tant que ça enfin on n'en
retrouve pas mal dans ces deux endroits
mais on ne retrouve pas ailleurs donc
voilà donc ça sert pas à grand chose
voilà ça pue niveau paléoenvironnements
c'est tellement atypique qu'on sait pas
trop lequel genre de paléoenvironnements
ces fossiles représentent donc bon voilà
donc ils sont pas très ils sont pas très
intéressant pour un géologue
voilà c'est surtout ça le truc pour un
paléontologue c'est très intéressant
pour reconstituer l'évolution des
invertébrés mais pour un géologue c'est
pas hyper intéressant donc on commence
par les mollusques et ont ce type là les
schistes de burgès et on passe direct à
la grande classification des invertébrés
avec les mollusques donc déjà les
mollusques ils tiennent leur nom du fait
que leurs corps est mou mais il est
recouvert d'une coquille dur et cette
coquille dur peut être fait d'une ou
deux valves donc les valves basse et les
coquilles des invertébrés donc enfin les
coquilles des mollusques donc les
huîtres par exemple ici vous avez une
huître et à la 2 valve et puis les
escargots ils n'ont qu'une valve et ces
mollusques que peuvent vivre fixer ou
non
donc certains vont vivre fixé comme
cette huître et d'autres vont bouger
comme cet escargot ici enfin ce
coquillage ici donc l'écologie
l'écologie c'est intéressant parce que
la pub un peu comme les comme les
cnidaires et comme les éponges
vous allez avoir des organismes qui vont
vivre dans des zones qui seront très qui
seront très agité et dans ce cas là ils
vont avoir une coquille très épaisse et
peut en augmenter comme par exemple
cette huître qui vit dans la zone où
l'eau dans la zone de battants de marée
donc là typiquement vous êtes sur une
une région où l'eau est très agitée il
ya des vagues tout le temps et puis vous
allez avoir des coquillages tropicaux
qui vont vivre dans des lagons dans des
eaux très calme et très riche et où ils
vont pouvoir grandir tout le temps parce
que l'eau est pas spécialement froide
donc leur métabolisme et pas ralenti et
cela est là ils vont développer de
belles ornementations donc là c'est
typiquement un coquillage de dodo de
basse énergie est tropical le premier
groupe de mollusques ans qu'elle on va
s'intéresser aujourd'hui ça va être les
céphalopodes c'est probablement le plus
important puisque c'est là qu'on va
trouver les ammonites alors comment on
reconnaît à céphalopode et surtout
comment on va différencier un
céphalopode d'un autres mollusques comme
un escargot qui a dès qu une copie très
similaires donc il y a qu une seule
d'une il n'y a qu'une seule valve comme
un escargot et cette valve est enroulé
sur elle même comme un escargot
mais contrairement à un escargot cette
valve va être divisé en chambre et ses
chambres vont être limités par des
lignes ma part des septs a donc ses
petits ces murs en fait entre les
chambres qui vont marquer des lignes de
sutures à la surface de votre de votre
coquille de la coquille de votre
céphalopode donc ça on ne trouve pas ça
chez les escargots chez les escargots il
n'y a qu'une seule qu'habiter à
l'intérieur de la coquille alors que là
il ya plein de petites cavités et chez
les escargots du coup on a pas de lignes
de sutures
en plus la l'enroulement de la copie
chez les céphalopodes est généralement à
plat alors que chez les gars alors que
chez les escargots c'est ce qu'on
appelle le le plan spirale alors que
chez les escargots ça va faire comme une
petite une petite spirale de chantilly
donc c'est pas planer spirale et chez
les ch et les escargots
alors on est embêté avec les
céphalopodes parce que le principe d'
actualiser dur à appliquer dans le sens
où la plupart des espèces modernes ont
perdu leur coquille
à part l'argonaute que vous voyez que
vous voyez ici et le nautile que vous
voyez là tous les céphalopodes que vous
connaissez donc les pieuvres et les
calmars ont perdu leur coquille ou on
une coquille qui est très reliques tu l
on va dire comme les seiches par exemple
vous connaissez l'os de seiche bas c'est
tout ce qui reste de la coquille donc
c'est même plus une coquille c'est juste
un résidu limite informe à l'intérieur
de l'animal qui n'est même plus à
l'extérieur de l'animal tellement c'est
plus une coquille mais c'est tout ce
qu'il reste de la coquille en fait mais
si vous regardez que de près en hausse
de 16 vous verrez les petits cet homme
vous verrez les lignes de sutures entre
les verrez qu'il ya des petits incrément
à l'intérieur et c'est tout ça c'est des
petites lignes de sutures
donc il ya toujours un peu la trace en
fait de cette de cette signature
céphalopode en fait mais du coup c'est
dur d'appliquer le principe de la
d'actualiser avec les céphalopodes
fossile donc notamment les ammonites qui
l avait des coquilles qui pouvait
parfois être super massive et s'est du
coup difficile d'interpréter ces
coquilles massive mais on va on va en
parler
l'écologie les céphalopodes sont tous
des carnivores et vivent tous dans la
mer donc ça c'est pas trop compliqué
alors constitué et ils vont être très
intéressant en termes de datation
puisque ils n'apparaissent qu'à
l'ordovicien si céphalopode donc
cambrien ils ne sont pas là on cambria
donc si vous trouvez à céphalopode déjà
vous savez que vous n'êtes pas en train
de regarder du coin du cambrien mais en
plus après il va y avoir différents
groupes qu'on va reconnaître en fonction
de leurs lignes de sutures qui vont qui
vont marquer en fait d'étranges de temps
très très précise donc d'abord le groupe
des nautiles aux ide donc le groupe qui
est un groupe qui apparaît dès lors de
vie siens pour le coup et qui a le
système de suture le plus simple puisque
vous n'avez les chambres sont séparés
par un septembre vous voyez qu'il ya qui
est relativement droit légèrement
concave et ça se voit la surface et ses
chambres en fait sur la surface du
fossile comme vous voyez ici vont se
refléter sous la forme d'une simple
ligne
donc il ya une ligne de suture qui est
juste droite et contrairement au zaman
aux ide qu'on va voir juste après les
nautiles aux ide ont un siphon qui est
central le siphon se trouve au milieu du
septum ce qui fait qu'il ya un petit
trou en plein milieu de votre fossiles
ici donc le groupe des nautiles aux ide
et lui-même divisé en ortho série des
dons knotty loide c'est le sait le rang
le plus haut et après on peut le diviser
en deux rangs inférieurs le rang
inférieur des orteaux série d et le rang
inférieur des nautiles idées les ortho
série des sons tout droit et ils ont
vécu de l'ordovicien au trias sic donc
ils sont essentiellement un marqueur de
l'ordovicien au trias pardon le trias 6
et en anglais de l'ordovicien au trias
donc ils sont essentiellement un
marqueur du paléozoïque avec une petite
languette qui dépasse au trias alors que
les nautiles aux ide eux ils
apparaissent au début du mésozoïque et
vivent encore aujourd'hui sur la forme
de notes du nautile moderne qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui est donc la grosse
différence c'est que là est enroulé le
nautile et l'autre pas les autos serre
et ce groupe des nautiles aux ide
il se distingue des hameaux no id
notamment par ses lignes de sutures donc
le septum chez les hameaux no id au lieu
d'être juste simple droits relativement
complexe il est plus en forme de s
chez les a' mono id ce qui fait que vous
allez avoir des lignes de sutures qui
vont être plus complexe et vous vous
avez aussi le siphon qui au lieu d'être
au milieu va se trouver dans ce qu'on
appelle la position ventrale parce que
quand vous tenez là monit de cette façon
exactement comme sur cette image en fait
est que vous prolonger le siphon jusque
sur le bord de la monitrice y est bien
il est du côté du ventre de l'animal est
pas du côté du dos de l'animal
donc c'est pour ça qu'on parle de
position ventrale mais ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est qu'en rôle au lieu d'être
au milieu il est sur le bord quoi le
siphon et ça c'est les deux grosses
différences avec les nautiles aux ide
les nautiles oh oui dans une future
simple et un siphon qui se trouve au
milieu alors que les hameaux no id ont
des structures complexes et on va voir
ce qu'on veut dire par complexe
et ils ont un siphon qui est en position
à côté vraiment posé sur la coquille en
fait sur le bord de la coquille donc il
ya une très très grande diversité damon
aux ide qu'on utilise beaucoup pour la
biostratigraphie en france on les
retrouve à peu près partout où l'on
retrouve des ammonites à peu près
partout dès que vous avez notamment dans
les alpes mais dès que vous avez une
montagne vous avez des harmoniques
dedans il ya beaucoup de jurassic et de
crétacé en france donc il ya beaucoup
d'amanites les seuls endroits où vous
n'avez vraiment pas pas la moindre
chance d'en trouver ça va être en
bretagne enfin dans les vieux massif
donc le massif armoricain en bretagne le
massif central et le massif des vosges
et encore le massif des vosges je crois
que vous pouvez quand même retrouvé à
certains endroits mais le reste de la
france est potentiellement riche en
ammonites après du moment que vous avez
un affleurement parce qu'évidemment si
vous vivez dans le bassin parisien et
qui a pas une colline ni une rivière qui
coupe les sédiments pour vous montrer
des vous montrer des affleurements
évidemment c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
d'aller voir s'il ya des ammonites
dedans donc il ya quatre grandes
familles dame au no id ces grandes
familles ce sont les gones ya titre les
sert à tit les ammonites donc gogniat
titre serra tite ammonites et les
hétéros morph je sais que les hétéros
morts sont un sous-groupe des ammonites
mais c'est bien de les distinguer à ce
niveau là parce qu'elles sont très très
différentes morphologiquement donc les
gones ya tits et les hameaux noïd les
plus simples puisque ils ont une suture
vous voyez en forme de s qui reflète
directement la forme du septum donc et
elles ont vécu du dévonien au permien
elles ont été ensuite succédé par les
serra titres qui ont une suture un peu
plus complexe qui forment des genres de
cuillères imbriqués les uns dans les
autres et qui ont vécu au trias donc les
gones yated sont les à mono id du
paléozoïque du dévonien jusqu au permien
les serra titres sont les premiers à
mono id du mésozoïque et ensuite au
mésozoïque vous allez avoir les
ammonites qui vont se développer à
partir du milieu du trias essais
ammonites elles vont avoir une structure
qui est très
complexe qu'on peut dire persillier
parce que ça ressemble à un brin de
persil ça veut pas dire que le cepd
sommes à l'intérieur est en forme de
persil ça va le cepd homme il est
toujours en forme de s à l'intérieur
mais pour une raison que l'on ignore
encore un peu c'est cette future est
extrêmement complexe et on ne sait pas
vraiment en tout cas moi je ne sais pas
et je n'ai jamais vu quelqu'un qui
prétendait le savoir il ya des
hypothèses évidemment aidé résistance au
stress des résines des hypothèses de
d'utilisation des fois de dimorphisme
sexuel d utilisation sexuelle mais voilà
il n'y a rien de rien de sûr comme je le
disais on a un gros problème de principe
d' actualiser avec ses ammonites on ne
sait pas pourquoi c'est ammonites avait
d énorme coquille alors que nos alors
que la plupart de nos céphalopode
moderne ne s'en passe totalement à tout
casser ammonites elles sont très faciles
elles sont très utilisées surtout le
mésozoïque du coup pour pour la
stratigraphie pour la biostratigraphie
parce que c'est suture persil et son
unique à chaque espèce
du moins on a défini les espèces
d'ammonites en fonction de la
morphologie de ses futurs persil et du
coup c'est un peu comme une empreinte
digitale ça permet d'identifier les
espèces d'ammonites paf bat pas super
facilement parce qu'évidemment il faut
connaître ces différences mais mais en
tout cas c'est on peut atteindre des
niveaux de précision stratigraphique
avec les ammonites de l'ordre de
quelques centaines de milliers d'années
donc inférieur à un million d'années
c'est remarquable c'est remarquable
le niveau de précision qu'on peut avoir
est le dernier groupe des mots no id
c'est les hétéros morte donc qui font
partie des ammonites donc ils ont aussi
une future persillier sauf que ces
hétéros morph sont déroulés donc il y en
a qui sont complètement déroulée comme
les comme les baculites ou ici les baux
qui unit qui sont complètement voix la
droite comme des orteaux sert donc la
seule différence avec un art auxerre ça
va être la complexité de la structure de
la coquille donc faut bien regarder la
suture
ce que si elle est toute droite ça
nantes auxerre 6 l et persil et c'est
une ça peut être une baculites ou une
bonne can eat enfin une de ses fameuses
et héros morts et puis vous avez
différents degrés de roulement de
deux noms en roulement de déroulage par
exemple ici vous avez mille osséja ce
qui est en forme de saxophones parce
qu'elle est encore un peu en rouler sur
les côtés on dirait un peu comme quand
tu as roulé un poster et puis tu essayes
de dérouler le poster et il sera en
roule tout seul ça ressemble un peu à ce
à quoi est donc tout ce beau monde
tout ce beau monde vous permet donc de
dater well et les hétéros morph viennent
du crétacé et du coup tout ce beau monde
vous permet de dater
en fait les terrains à partir du milieu
du dévonien jusqu au crétacé de façon
assez précise
les gones ya tite vous permettre de dire
que c'est des ammonites du paléo de la
fin du paléozoïque les serre at it vous
indique le trias les ammonites vous
indique le trias le jurassique le
crétacé les hétéros morph vous indique
le crétacé donc en fait si vous trouvez
des ammonites mais vous que vous trouvez
pas des terreaux mort vous pouvez plus
ou moins dire que vous êtes sûre du
jurassique
enfin si vous trouvez les ammonites mais
que vous trouvez ni des hétéros morfle
ni desserra tite vous pouvez plus ou
moins dire que vous êtes en train de
regarder du jurassique puisque il ya que
là que les ammonites et n'avait aucun
des deux groupes donc au final vous
pouvez faire fin du paléozoïque trias
jurassique crétacé à condition d'avoir
une certaine abondance de 2 c à mono id
donc c'est vraiment vraiment super cool
et à la fin du crétacé les ammonites
s'éteignent donc si vous trouvez 0
ammonites ben c'est que vous êtes
possiblement soit avant qu'elle est
apparue sur la préquelle et disparus ou
que vous êtes tout simplement pas dans
un milieu où les ammonites vivait
et l'autre grand groupe de céphalopodes
qu'on va voir aujourd'hui c'est les
belles emnid névés les minutes qui ne
sont pas enroulés en fait les belles et
mme dit c'est même pas d'écho qui en
fait c'est juste la petite pointe qu'il
y aille au bout de la coquille et qu'on
retrouve encore aujourd'hui chez les
sèche alors ça ne veut pas dire que les
baies limite son décès choix elles sont
proches parents ne dessèche
donc si on appelle ça le rostre et dans
ce que vous trouvez les baies les
menottes et ben c'est ces fossiles en
balle de fusil en forme de balle de
fusil qui sont qui sont généralement
bien brillant comme ça et ça et c'est en
fait juste le bout de la coquille d'un
animal qui ressemblait à une sèche et
qui vivait exclusivement mésozoïque
dutriat sic au crétacé donc généralement
on trouve ces nus milite cb les minutes
pardon on les retrouve aux côtés des
ammonites ce qui fait qu'on ce qui fait
qu'elles sont très très très très
utilisée aussi en stratigraphie mais
comme comme elles ont toutes à peu près
sept têtes de balle de fusil
c'est un peu plus difficile à utiliser
que les ammonites évidemment vous avez
des variations mais elles sont un peu
plus subtil on va dire que sur les
futurs persil et des ammonites
généralement vous ne trouverez pas la
coquille qu'on appelle le fragment
caunes bien que des fois vous avez des
préservation exceptionnelles où vous
trouverez des bouts de fragments caunes
et dans ce cas là vous voyez les lignes
de sutures dessus qui sont très très
simple exactement comme sur cet os de
seiche ici donc par opposition aux mots
aux mollusques céphalopodes
on va maintenant voir les mollusques
gastéropodes qui eux aussi ont une
coquille enroulée comme les ammonites
sauf que cet enroulement n'est pas donc
c'est une seule coquille déjà donc une
valve enroulée sauf que cette coquille
est spirale elle n'est pas plat ni
spirale donc c'est une coquille qui
s'enroule comme de la chantilly en fait
ce qu'on voit très bien par exemple ici
bien qu' il ya des exceptions comme les
plats normes mais il n'y a que les
planeurs ben qui font exception et même
si vous tombez sur une plate forme il y
à un moyen de savoir qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'une ammonites et c'est de voir qu'il
n'ya aucune ligne de suture ni aucun
symptôme
parce que il n'ya qu'une valve et elle
ne contient qu'une seule chambre
cette valve donc les gastéropodes c'est
vraiment le truc avec lequel il faut
surtout pas confondre les hameaux noïd
parce que parce qu'il ya parce que
évidemment c'est le piège classique j'ai
envie de dire comptant aux étudiants
donc leur écologie ce qui est alors les
gastéropodes sont intéressants parce
qu'on les retrouve depuis la mer jusqu'à
la terre vous avez des gastéropodes qui
sont terrestres les escargots notamment
ici vous avez quelques fossiles de casse
théropodes d'escargots typiquement du
pliocène qui sont terrestres
du coup donc j'ai du bon gros escargot
de bourgogne
vous avez les planeurs qui vivent dans
le dans l'eau douce et qui sont très
reconnaissables puisqu'elles ont leurs
coquilles plan spirale est donc là pour
le coup c'est très facile de reconnaître
les planeurs ben et du coup de des
marqueurs d'eau douce des marqueurs de
dépôt d'eau douce et vous avez les
coquillages classique qui vous indiquent
qu' en fonction de leur ornementation
vous indiqueront un environnement marin
plutôt agitée ou non encore une fois ça
s'applique avec les gastéropodes plus
ils sont plus ils sont en augmenter et
plus ils vivaient dans un environnement
calme et plus ils ont des coquilles tout
épaisse et est contracté et plus ils
vivent
il y vit dans des environnements agitée
on suppose que c'est la même chose
d'ailleurs avec les ammonites y j'ai
oublier d'aborder sa mais avec les
ammonites c'est pareil vous avez des
gros ammonites avec des grosses épines
bien épaisse bien fat celle-là on
suppose qu'elle vivait dans le fond des
océans et qu'elle se faisait un peu
balloté avec avec les marées et vous
avez les ammonites qui sont aplaties
enfin qu'ils sont très qui sont très
hydrodynamique avec une coquille très
fine et celle là elle vivait plutôt ça
c'était des nageuses quoi donc en
fonction pareil de la morphologie des
ammonites vous allez avoir différentes
différents types de d'écologie vous
allez avoir aussi les harmoniques qui
sont dont on voit que le dernier tour
qui sont des nageuses et les ammonites
dont on voit tous les tours comme sept
aps la norme et qui sont pas des neiges
du coup mais ça c'est pareil encore une
fois on souffre de l'absence de
comparaison avec des espèces modernes
donc même si ce sont des hypothèses qui
bien étayé ça reste des hypothèses on
est plutôt d'accord là-dessus enfin
après il faut comparer aussi avec les
types d'environnements si vous trouvez
si vous êtes dans un environnement de
lagon et que vous trouvez une ammonite
avec des grosses pointes c'est soit que
cette ammonites a été transportée soin
de votre interprétation de
l'environnement de lagon est fausse
voilà mais c'est qu'il ya un problème
du coup bref les bivalves maintenant les
bivalves donc céder contrairement aux
gastéropodes et aux ammonites qu'on
vient de voir ses bibal
ils ont deux valves comme leurs noms
l'indiquent bivalves donc c'est là qu'on
va voir les moules les huîtres les
pecten donc les coquilles saint jacques
et tous les machins qui ont deux
coquilles quoi les couteaux etc etc
les arches de noé si vous connaissez ce
coquillage très jolie l'esp on deale etc
etc
donc les bivalves ils ont 2 valve est en
fait la limite 30 ans et 2 valve forment
un axe de symétrie entre les deux valent
donc les deux valves sont les mêmes ce
qui vous est représentée ici donc ça
c'est un bivalves moderne les deux
valves sont les mêmes et ici à molly un
mollusque fossiles ou les deux valves
sont mêmes enfin bivalves fossiles ou
les deux valves sont mêmes donc ça c'est
vrai depuis l'origine des bivalves à
l'ordovicien donc ce qui est ça c'était
enfin de même au cambrien d'ailleurs je
dis des bêtises
l'heureuse donc ça c'est vrai depuis
l'origine des bivalves au cambrien c'est
vivable ils ont d écologie très variés
aussi vous avez des bivalves d'eau douce
des bivalves de mer est encore une fois
l'ornementation de l'aco qui va refléter
l'énergie et la température
les bivalves d'eau douce sont très
intéressants pour les ajustements pour
les environnements d'eau douce vous avez
notamment les moules du genre unis eau
qui sont des moules qui vivent
uniquement en milieu soit soit d'eau
douce soit d'estuaire donc là c'est par
exemple une moule de douces ici donc
c'est un marqueur d'un environnement
continental et non pas d'un
environnement marin donc c'est très
intéressant de savoir ces différences
entre les bivalves d'eau douce et les
bivalves qui ne sont pas d'eau douce et
vous avez est ce qu'il va être
intéressant au niveau datation c'est de
savoir que les bivalves en fait était
pas du tout dominant au paléozoïque les
coquillages dominant au paléozoïque
c'est lé brachiopodes les brachiopodes
ils ont à peu près le même mode de vie
que l'ebit val c'est à dire qu'ils
vivent
globalement fixé et ils vont filtrer
l'eau comme les bivalves et il aimait il
était meilleur à ce petit jeu là haut
paléozoïque qui ne le sont devenus
ensuite plus tard donc au paléozoïque il
y a assez peu de bivalves et d'un seul
coup au mésozoïque ils vont devenir
dominants donc c'est ce qui est écrit
ici au paléo zurich ils étaient rares et
au mésozoïque ils sont devenus dominant
donc
donc il ya ce chiffre en fait c'est pas
parce que vous trouvez un bivalves que
vous êtes forcément dans le mésozoïque
par contre si vous trouvez beaucoup
beaucoup de bivalves et pas beaucoup de
brachiopodes alors vous pouvez savoir
dans une certaine marge d'erreur vous
pouvez être confiant dans le fait que
vous êtes plutôt en train de regarder du
mésozoïque il y avait toujours des
brachiopodes au mésozoïque mais il y en
avait moins que des bivalves voilà donc
odin paléozoïque dominé et au mésozoïque
dominant et justement ça nous amène au
brachiopodes qui sont aussi des
organismes à 2 valve mais on ne les
appelle pas des bivalves ce sont ces
appartient à un autre une autre branche
du grand arbre des invertébrés qui
s'appelle les lofofora tas d lofofora
rien parce que l'organisme fils tu rates
enfin l'organe qu'ils utilisent pour
filtrer et est complètement différent de
l'organe qu'utilisent les bivalves pour
filtrer donc on peut pas les ont peut
pas du tout les mettre dans le même dans
même groupe donc les brachiopodes c'est
complètement différent des bivalves mais
ça ça y ressemble superficiellement
parce qu'ils ont de valve et ils ont un
mode de une écologie assez similaires
c'est à dire qu'ils vivent fixé dans le
fond des océans ou plus ou moins
immobile au fond des océans
mais la différence mais il ya des
différences majeures et cette différence
majeure c'est qu'en fait les 2 valve ne
sont pas les mêmes les valves sont
différentes donc j'ai un brachiopodes
vous avez deux valves différentes
il y en a une qui est plus grande que
l'autre est la plus grande des deux
valves en fait elle porte un petit trou
donc ça c'est pareil ça n'existe pas
chez les bivalves le petit trou qui
servent à l'assertion du pied ou qu'on
appelle le pdis l essai se séparent ce
pied en fait que les brachiopodes se
fixe au fond d'eux au fond des océans
donc
donc vous avez vraiment ces deux plans
d'organisation totalement différente à
savoir les brachiopodes fallait les
bivalves qui ont deux valves symétrique
donc un axe de symétrie qui passe par le
plan de fermeture des deux valves donc
ce qu'on pourrait appeler un plan de
faire un plan de symétrie horizontale
alors que les brachiopodes on2 que qui
différentes et le plan de symétrie ne
passe pas par là par la structure entre
les deux coquilles il passe c'est une
symétrie en fait qui est bilatérale
si vous préférez qui passe verticalement
et en fait c'est l'écho qui sont
symétriques mais seulement avec elle
même donc vous avez donc pour faire
simple généralement ce que je dis aux
étudiants c'est que vous avez un plan de
symétrie horizontale avec les bivalves
alors que chez les braquer au poste vous
avez un plan de symétrie verticale dans
le sens où il ya évidemment faut tenir
le coquillage dans le bon sens mais
voilà si vous si votre coquillages n'a
pas les coquilles qui sont les deux
valves qui sont exactement les mêmes
alors vous êtes en train de regarder à
brachiopodes évidemment encore une fois
vous avez des exceptions notamment au
sein des bivalves vous avez les rues
d'ist qui lru disque qui ont une
coquille
dont les deux co qui ne sont pas du tout
symétrique vous avez les huîtres vous
avez les griffes et qui ne qui n'ont pas
l'écho qui symétrique donc ça marche en
général mais évidemment si vous allez
dans le détail ça va commencer à un
péché donc c'est brachiopodes ils sont
reconnaissables aussi du coup par le
pdis elle c'est là qu'il faut c'est là
où il faut faire intervenir justement
d'autres caractères tels que le trou
pour le pdi celle qui est présent chez
tous les brachiopodes qui est absent
chez les ch et les bivalves alors jeudi
chez tous les brachiopodes sauf un la
réguler d'ailleurs l'un des derniers
brachiopodes survivant aujourd'hui
puisque comme comme je lé 10 août à
l'heure les brachiopodes sont
intéressants d'un point de vue datation
puisque ils sont largement dominant ou
paléozoïque et contrairement aux
bivalves ils vont devenir rare à partir
du mésozoïque et dans le séno unique
particulièrement donc au mésozoïque vous
avez encore une bonne chance de trouver
des brachiopodes dans les gisements
jurassique crétacé notamment mais à
partir du cénozoïque là ça devient très
difficile de trouver des bras qui oppose
à parler l'un gül qui sont encore assez
assez bien représenté encore aujourd'hui
ça veut pas dire qu'il ya plus du tout
brachiopodes a parlé d'un gül mais il ya
d'autres mais disons que les langues ils
sont les plus communes et les langues
ils sont intéressantes parce que ce sont
des marqueurs d'eau saumâtre daud daud
un peu salée mais pas trop c'est pas
encore de l'eau de mer voilà donc je
voulais retrouver dans les lagunes dans
les estuaires par exemple est allé très
reconnaissable puisque c'est la seule
salle télé qui n'a pas dit qui n'a pas
de trou pour le pdi celle où aller que
le pdis à lille sort directement entre
les deux valves donc ya pas de suture
entre les deux valves et il ya juste
mais bon c'est allez allez très
reconnaissable à la guinée l'allalin gül
et c'est la seule chez qui il n'y a pas
le pdis elle donc tous les autres ont
tapé disent elles et puis évidemment les
brachiopodes trait commun vous avez
l'esprit fair il était très diversifiées
au paléozoïque il n'était pas seulement
dominant en nombre mais il était
dominant aussi en diversité en menant en
diversité morphologique donc au
paléozoïque vous allez trouver beaucoup
beaucoup d'espèces différentes de
brachiopodes et pas seulement beaucoup
en quantité mais aussi beaucoup en
diversité
maintenant on va vers les arthropodes
alors les arthropodes ce sont les
invertébrés dominant il domine le monde
littéralement de 90% de 90% mais plus de
la moitié de la diversité des animaux
sur terre est faite de d'arthropodes et
notamment d'insectes donc c'est vraiment
les c'est vraiment les animaux qui
domine en termes de diversité même s'ils
sont petits et ces arthropodes donc ils
sont reconnaissables sont
reconnaissables à leur orgueil leur plan
d'organisation donc au lieu d'avoir une
coquille avec une valve ou de valve en
fait ils ont une coquille qui est formé
de plein de segments et ces segments
sont articulés les uns avec les autres
c'est pour ça qu'on les appelle des
arthropodes art trop pour articulations
epode les pieds les pieds donc ils ont
les pattes articulées parce que
justement ils ont ces segments
en fait de l'exosquelette qui fout de
coquilles qui forment le leur lorsque lé
est externe
donc c'est ce que vous voyez chez tous
ces arthropodes que ce soit des insectes
des scorpions des crustacés voilà des
arachnides ils ont tous ce corps qui est
fait de deux segments articuler les uns
avec les autres de segments
d'exosquelette articuler les uns avec
les autres
ces arthropodes il existe depuis le
cambrien et ils ont conquis absolument
tous les milieux donc vous allez avoir
des arthropodes qui sont typiques du
milieu terrestre comme les insectes vous
allez avoir des arthropodes typique du
milieu marin et même à l'intérieur des
différents milieux marins vous allez
avoir des arthropodes qui vont vivre
dans différentes écologie certains vont
engager certaines vont vivre dans le
fond donc évidemment le groupe
d'arthropodes fossiles le plus connu le
plus le plus remarquable c'est celui des
trilobites qu'on retrouve absolument
partout durant tout le paléozoïque et
uniquement durant le paléozoïque donc
c'est un très bon marqueur
stratigraphique du paléozoïque et après
vous avez différentes espèces qui vont
être qu'ils vont être servir de marqueur
stratigraphique à travers le paléozoïque
donc vous avez des biozone aussi qu'ils
sont définir tous tous pour tout ou
partie par leur contenu en trilobites
dont les trilobites c'est pas compliqué
tri
ça tient pour 3
parce qu'ils sont divisés en 3 loeb et
en trois segments donc les trois lobes
ce sont les lobes que vous voyez sur le
thorax donc un deux trois donc les deux
plèvre sur le côté et le lobe axial au
milieu donc c'est ce que vous voyez sur
celui-là 1 2 3 loeb 2 plèvre et le lobe
axial et trois segments la tête le corps
qu'on appelle thorax et là que qu'on
appelle le pij il y sommes donc voilà
trilobites 3 3 segments 3 loeb très
facile à identifier grâce à ça donc la
tête
elle a aussi ce qu'on appelle une
glabelle donc la glabelle c'est ce qu'on
pourrait appeler le nez en fait et sur
le côté vous avez des joues mobiles et
les joues mobile se décroche quand
l'animal mu et il pouvait sortir par la
tête en fait de son il pouvait sortir de
son ancien exosquelette par la tête
quand ils muet on sait ça parce qu'il ya
de très très beaux fossiles préservé qui
ont qui ont préservé cette ce phénomène
donc les trilobites généralement vivait
plutôt au fond des océans bien qu'il y
ait eu quelques formes nageuse donc
c'est plutôt à une forme d'eau peu
profonde dans des océans
ouais c'est plutôt une forme d'eau peu
profonde mais qui vivaient dans le fond
et on les retrouve du coup que dans le
paléozoïque mais où ils ont où ils
permettent de faire des corrélations
assez précise un autre groupe
d'arthropodes important au moins dans un
contexte dans un contexte sud africain
c'est celui des kelly sert alors on les
calices des ligues et des kelly ceyrat
pardon donc les quais lycée rade c'est
là qu'on retrouve les araignées les
scorpions et les limites qui sont tous
unis par le fait qu'ils partagent un
corps divisé en deux segments seulement
contrairement aux trilobites qui avait
trois segments contrairement aux
insectes aussi qu'ils ont trois segments
vous avez la tête donc le céphalothorax
donc la tête et le corps sont fusionnés
et un abdomen et de temps en temps vous
avez une petite que qu'on appelle le tel
sommet elle est pas tout le temps là
notamment chézard signé par exemple n'y
a pas de telles sont est-ce qu'il va les
distinguer c'est aussi l'heure un pénis
bucco donc les
les quais lycée ratenon pas d'antenne
contrairement aux trilobites mais bon
les trilobites c'est très rare que les
antennes soient préservés de toute façon
mais les calices et ratenon pas
d'antenne contrairement aux trilobites
contrairement aux crustacés
contrairement aux insectes
par contre par contre ils ont une double
paire d'un pénis bucco donc ce qu'on
appelle les kelly serre est ce qu'on
appelle les parties buccale donc les
kelly sert ce sont les grilles d espèce
d'énorme crochet qu'on les araignées
c'est les passes des crabes et puis chez
les ch et les chais les lits muls et
aussi des pinces mais plus petit et puis
après vous avez les parties buccale qui
sont vraiment ce qu'on pourrait appeler
les mandibules quoi en fait donc voilà
les les énorme crochet des araignées là
où il ya le venin ce sont les calices
air et c'est le même a pas dit ce qui
porte les pinces chez les scorpions plus
tôt c'est plutôt intéressant comme comme
phénomène de voir cette divergence en
fait les différentes utilisations qu'on
pu faire deux groupes de kelly ceyrat
avec le même organe lesquels is here at
on les retrouve dans le sait dans les
océans comme les lits mules ou sur en
milieu terrestre comme les scorpions les
araignées d'ailleurs les spl la sortie
des eaux par les scorpions il est assez
bien documenté on sait que les premiers
les premiers scorpions vivait dans les
océans du mois les ancêtres des
scorpions vivait dans les océans étaient
déjà des prédateurs des prédateurs
important durant le paléozoïque et puis
ensuite on retrouve les premiers
scorpion sur la terre et notamment en
afrique du sud puisque on a le plus
ancien un scorpion terrestre en afrique
du sud qui s'appelle gondwana scorpions
dont vous pouvez voir ici
pellicer avec la passe dessus et puis
ici une des pâtes
donc c'est les restos très fragmentaires
mais qui permettent déjà de dire qu'on
avait un des scorpions terrestre au
carbonifère en afrique
et puis avant ça vous avez les scorpions
de mer qu'on appelle les horribles
terride voilà dont je parlais les grands
prédateurs marins qui ressemblait déjà à
des scorpions donc qu'ils étaient des
grands qu'ils étaient des prédateurs
plus ou moins grands et qu'on retrouve
de l'ordovicien au permien qui se
distingue des scorpions finalement parce
que
déjà vous voyez qu'ils sont pas toujours
des pinces et ils ont des appendices
nageurs et ils n'ont pas de dard
venimeux à l'arrière du corps
puis vous avez d'autres groupes qui sont
très utilisés parmi les artisans pod
donc d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
je disais c'est important dans un
contexte sud africain c'est parce qu'on
a le premier scorpions vrai terrestres
etc on a aussi pas mal de ripd et reid
c'est pour ça que je disais que c'était
important de parler des calices et rate
même si au final ils sont relativement
anecdotique dans le sens où on ne
retrouve pas beaucoup et que du coup ils
sont pas beaucoup sont pas très
utilisable du point de vue stratégique
rafic et du point de vue écologique
enfin paléo écologique
après vous avez des arthropodes qui sont
très utilisable du point de vue
stratigraphique notamment les vous avez
les australes code donc qui ressemble
qui sont des alors ils ce sont des
crustacés mais bivalves donc ce sont des
crustacés à de valve mais à l'intérieur
des deux valves ya un petit crustacé et
je crois qu'ils se servent de leurs
antennes pour filtrer la nourriture et
l'amenait rechute à l'intérieur de leur
coquille et donc ils ressemblent à des
petits haricots cd micro ce cd
organismes microscopiques enfin
microscopiques mais plutôt petit
généralement considéré comme des
microfossiles et qui ressemblent à des
petits haricots et l'ornementation de
leur coquille permet de les identifier
chaque espèce à une ornementation de
coquilles différentes
on les retrouve dans les eaux on les
retrouve dans les eaux de mer mais aussi
dans les eaux dans les eaux douces et il
date du cambrien et on les retrouve du
cambrien jusqu'à aujourd'hui donc ce qui
fait que le volant pour le confort peut
faire fonctionner le principe de
l'actualité quand il s'agit de les
interpréter mais par contre ça limite
leur utilisation en tant que que
marqueur stratigraphique bien que dans
le paléozoïque les espèces ont l'air
d'être suffisamment distingue pour qu'il
soit très très utilisés comme marqueurs
bio stratigraphique dans le paléozoïque
vous avez les insectes marqueur du
milieu terrestre par excellence qu'on
retrouve depuis le dernier jusqu'à
aujourd'hui donc un petit peu comme les
tétrapodes ils sont sortis quand même de
l'eau avant les tétrapodes qui sont
reconnaissables au fait qu'ils ont des
ailes généralement pas les collemboles
mais que la plupart d'entre eux ont des
ailes qu'ils ont des antennes et qu'ils
ont évidemment trois paires de trois
paires de membres dont six pattes au
lieu de haut-lieu des huit qu'on
rencontre chez les ch et les arachnides
par exemple et on les retrouve et donc
ces insectes on les retrouve rarement en
tant que faux cils mais comme ils sont
très abondants aujourd'hui ça me semble
assez essentiel de les couvrir
évidemment il faut des préservation très
très
finn dans des sédiments très très faim
d'élagage tâte typiquement pour pouvoir
préserver de bohain sectes comme celui
là qui vient du cratère doha tu as donc
qui est un cratère volcanique qui a été
ensuite rempli par les sédiments très
fin d'un lac de cratère dans lequel on
retrouve ces très jolies insectes et
puis vous avez les myriapodes donc qui
en
alors je crois que c'est en zoulou
s'appelle deschamps godolo donc je les
écris là parce que je trouve le mot très
drôle est que tout le monde le trouve
très drôle surtout quand je le prononce
donc ce sont les mille pattes
évidemment c'est myriapodes qu'on
retrouve depuis le silurien qui était
parmi les premiers qui étaient parmi les
premiers arthropodes à conquérir le
milieu terrestre
évidemment les lézards trop peu reid du
carbonifère les 1000 pas de géant sont
les plus connus bien qu'on ne retrouve
pas en afrique du sud et pour terminer
ce coup là c'est vrai les échinodermes
avec donc les les étoiles de mer et les
oursins qui sont les qui sont les
échinodermes les plus nombreux les plus
communs mais on retrouve aussi donc les
listes de mer dans la famille des
échinodermes et les concombres de mer
qui sont pas du tout connu
quand on a très peu de fossiles donc on
va pas en parler tant que ça mais tous
tous absolument tous les échinodermes se
conforment pas aux mêmes plans
d'organisation un savoir une symétrie
pintard radiés donc c'est à dire une
symétrie par axe 5
donc vous avez cinq fois le même motif
qui se répète en cercle ou alors c'est
un multiple de 5
il faut que j'essaie de trouver voilà
vous avez ici par exemple une étoile de
mer je crois que celle la lave un bras
et vous pouvez avoir 25 vous pouvez
avoir 40 vous pouvez avoir autant de
break vous voulez tant que c'est un
multiple de 5
donc les échinodermes sont très très ont
un plan d'organisation qui est très très
conserver et comme tous les invertébrés
ils ont une coquille qui est en
carbonate de calcium
ce qui est important de mentionner parce
qu'en fait ils sont proches parents ce
sont les invertébrés qui sont les plus
proches parents des fins ce sont les
invertébrés à coquille faut le préciser
qui sont le plus proches parents des
vertébrés donc leur coquille
être en carbonate de calcium elle n'est
pas comme l'os des vertébrés elle n'est
pas en phosphate de calcium
donc c'est important de le préciser à ce
niveau là et c'est une coquille externe
n'est pas interne que contrairement aux
vertébrés qui ont un squelette interne
donc c'est échinodermes sont
généralement des plus tôt des filtres
heures qui vivent à accrocher ou plus ou
moins accrochée au fond des océans sont
pas vraiment accroché par exemple les
étoiles de mer et les oursins sont pas
accroché mais on peut pas dire que ce
soit les champions du rallye 100 m donc
c'est plutôt des formes qui vivent au
fond et qui se déplace qui où ce ne se
déplace pas où se déplacent lentement
avec l'exception des listes de mer qui
sont capables de se décrocher d'aller
nager pour se déplacer mais c'est pour
aller se raccrocher ailleurs en fait
donc c'est pas non plus des organismes
qui vivent normalement dans l'est vivent
normalement de façon pélagiques voilà
pélagiques c'est quand ton âge là c'est
plutôt des organismes benthiques donc
qui vivent dans le fond des océans
on les retrouve depuis le cambrien et
ils sont intéressants du point de vue
bio stratigraphique notamment les cris
no id parce que l'écrit no id
il était très très très abondants aux
paléozoïque et d'un seul coup au
mésozoïque et ils ont disparu de la
circulation
en fait ils n'ont pas totalement disparu
puisqu'il ya encore des cris nos vies
d'aujourd'hui qu'on appelle les listes
de mer mais ces cris no id en fait ils
sont passés de complètement dominant sur
le de des échinodermes dominant on va
dire ils sont passés d'un seul coup
d'oeil au statut de on vit juste dans le
fond mais vraiment dans le fond fond des
océans
voilà dans les traits dans des eaux très
profondes donc plus de mille mètres de
profondeur
donc du coup bah voilà donc on les
retrouve plus après dans le registre
fossile parce que les eaux profondes à
partir du mésozoïque les eaux qui était
profonde au mésozoïque sont toujours
généralement des eaux profondes
aujourd'hui en fait donc en tout cas à
partir du jurassique peut-être pas au
trias mais à partir du jurassique vous
avez les océans moderne qui se forment
donc les eaux qui était profonde à
l'époque sont toujours des eaux
profondes aujourd'hui donc du coup on
trouve pas leurs fossiles
donc ils sont très dominant très très
nombreux au paléo zoric notamment à
l'ordovicien et au dévonien très très
très abondant à l'ordovicien érodé venir
ils commencent à se raréfier au
carbonifère et ouais à partir du
mésozoïque on en a presque plus on en
trouve presque plus qui veut pas dire
qu'ils sont plus là et ils sont fixés au
fond avec une tige donc ce que vous
voyez ici la tige qui se termine par des
petites des petites tentacules qui
permettent de s'agripper ils ont cette
longue tige donc ça c'est les seuls
échinodermes avoir une tige donc ça
permet de les reconnaître parmi les
échinodermes et on reconnaît leur
symétrie pintadier dans leurs bras voyez
qu'ils ont des très longs bras dont ils
peuvent se servir pour nager voyez il se
casse au niveau de la du calice ici sont
donc cette partie centrale qui tient
tous les bras c'est ce qu'on appelle le
calice au milieu du calice il y à la
bouche et les organes se trouvaient à
l'intérieur et ils peuvent se casser à
la base du calice est en fait en battant
des bras ils peuvent nager mais ses bras
ils servent surtout de tentacules dont
ils se servent pour attraper la
nourriture et la conduire jusqu'à leur
bouche
en fait mais on donc et on retrouve la
symétrie patins radié en fait dans le
nombre de bras vous voyez un deux trois
quatre cinq et même quand on regarde les
petits éléments qui constituent l'animal
vous voyez tous ces petits éléments
articuler les uns aux autres tout ça
c'est ce qu'on appelle des articles des
articles de krynn aux ide et même quand
on regarde ces petits aliments des
éléments articuler les uns aux autres et
ben on retrouve cette symétrie pintard
aviez vous voyez l'intérieur ici où les
organes mou se trouvait un deux trois
quatre cinq comme une étoile de mer
et si vous avez les articulations en
fait entre les éléments donc ces petits
articles de crinolines voulais retrouver
très souvent de façon isolée mais quand
nous en retrouver un vous savez qu'il y
avait des cris no id et donc vous avez
vous savez vous avez une énorme
probabilité d'être soit quelque part
entre le gris le début de leurs devis
siens à la fin du déjeuner ans donc
c'est plutôt donc c'est très intéressant
du point de vue stratigraphique et du
point de vue écologique
vous savez que si vous voulez trouver
dans le paléozoïque vous êtes plutôt sur
des eaux peu profondes alors que dans le
mésozoïque elle cénozoïque vous êtes
plutôt dans les eaux très profondes
vous avez les étoiles de mer qui sont
pas très très nombreuses enfin les
astéroïdes les aux furies donc les
étoiles de mer et les au fur qui sont
pas très nombreuses dans le registre
fossile mais qu'on retrouve curieusement
beaucoup en afrique du sud est notamment
vous avez cette plaque qui est
magnifique qui vient du dévonien
d'afrique du sud où vous avez des justes
des milliers des milliers de dauphins
juré de et des toiles de mer et c'est
juste magnifique
c'est tout et c'est juste pour ça que
j'ai mis sept diapos parce que autrement
ils servent à rien mais je veux dire ils
apparaissent alors deux lycéens sont
toujours présents aujourd'hui ils ont
rien de spécial niveau
paléoenvironnements cc des prédateurs de
du fond des océans qui vivent dans les
eaux froides comme chaude donc ils sont
pas super intéressant ni en haut niveau
de paléo ni au niveau
paléoenvironnements ni au niveau ni au
niveau stratigraphique mais ils sont
juste hyper abondant dans le débonnaire
d'afrique du sud et voyez comme on en
trouve des milliers et des milliers
c'est juste prodigieux quoi
et ils sont très reconnaissables
puisqu'ils ont cinq bras et enfin le
dernier groupe est encore un des plus
intéressants beaucoup plus intéressant
du moins que les étoiles de mer du point
de vue bio stratigraphique ce sont les
et quinault id donc les oursins donc les
oursins qui sont généralement deux
formes ferry qui sont généralement de
forme sphérique ou plates et qui ont
généralement des épines ou alors une
sorte de duvet c'est les épines qui se
sont réduites l'anus se trouve au sommet
de l'animal donc c'est ce qu'on appelle
la face à bord al et ils se trouvent et
la bouche se trouve sur la face au buzz
est opposée qu'on appelle la face du
coup orale et le corps est divisé en
cinq zones ou un multiple de 5 zones
elles mêmes divisées en deux types de
plaques
les plaques qui porte les pattes donc
les les oursins ils ont des petits pieds
ils arrivent à se déplacer avec leurs
petits pieds des genres de tentacules
plutôt enfin bref c'est ils ont des
petits pieds et ses petits pieds il
passe par des troubles qui se trouve sur
les faces du coup qu'on appelle en bus
la crème en bus la craie repas ce qu'il
ya en bulles qui permettent de bouger et
vous avez les épines donc qui peuvent
être très grosse des x 2 qui ressemblent
à des grosses masses eu trait
caractéristique qui se trouve elle
attachée sur les zones dites inter en
bus la crème et donc sur le sur le
créneau est lui même ça se trouve sur le
les kinoïdes lui-même
ça se traduit par la présence de ces
petits de ces petites bosses mais
souvent vous allez retrouver les épines
isolé alors ses épines isolées elles ont
une forme très caractéristique des fois
en épines mais des fois en forme de
bateau comme ça avec cette petite zone
d'articulation qui est très très
reconnaissable
donc qui permet de les identifier
facilement et vous allez avoir deux
types d'oursins du coup vous allez avoir
les oursins d'irrégulier c'est à dire
les oursins en boule et les oursins
irrégulier qui vont généralement avoir
soi une forme de coeur soit voire même
une forme plate mais en tout cas quoi
qu'il arrive dont la dont la symétrie
pintard adyal est altérée donc ils vont
avoir une symétrie qui est quasiment
bilatérales comme vous pouvez le voir
voire franchement bilatérale pour
certains donc c'est intéressant de
comparer donc d'abord les oursins
régulier c'est les plus anciens c'est ce
qu'ils apparaissent dès lors de vie sien
et qui sont toujours présents
aujourd'hui et ils ce sont des oursins
qui sont sphériques dont les zones
intérieures
ambühl a créé un ter en but la création
organisé de façon pas ta radial parfaite
très facile à reconnaître et dont les
épines sont généralement très très
grosse c'est chez eux qu'on va retrouver
ce genre de grosses épines d'un
typiquement en forme de bahts alors que
vous avez d'autres côté les oursins
irrégulier et ses sources un irrégulier
donc déjà la symétrie parade hier est
altérée en fait par le fait que là vous
voyez les zones en bus la cre air sont
réduites elles ne vont pas jusque
jusqu'à là on est sur la face à bord al
elle ces zones en bus la crise ne
s'étende pas jusqu'à la phase orale donc
elles sont que sur la partie supérieure
en face en fait de l'oursin ces zones
dambulla chrtr de fait la symétrie
bilatérale est altérée de plus vous
pouvez voir que le l'anus à bouger
jusqu'ici il n'est plus sur le sommet
mais il a bougé
de ce côté là et vous pouvez voir que la
bouche ici à bouger de ce côté ci donc
ça c'est certainement parce que c'est au
sein irrégulier contrairement aux
oursins régulier ne sont pas des
prédateurs
ce sont des filtres heures donc ils
filtrent le sable et du coup la bouche
s'oriente de telle façon à mieux capter
le sable pour que le sable rentrer plus
facilement dans la bouche alors que chez
ces gros oursins et régulier
la bouche vous voyez très très grosse et
à l'intérieur vous avez des grosses
dents qu'on appelle la lanterne
d'aristote qui servent à broyer les
coquilles des petits coquillages dont le
les oursins se nourrissent donc ça aussi
ça correspond aussi à deux modes de vie
complètement différents prédateurs ici
et filtreurs là et donc l'altération de
cette symétrie paradis est très typique
et on a aussi le fait qu'il n'y a plus
vraiment des pin en tout cas les épines
sont réduites à un petit duvet donc
c'est presque doux c'est pas des oursins
qui piquent pour le coup c'est un petit
duvet qui est tout doux et ce petit
duvet tout doux et bien il est accroché
des zones interrompu la crèche qui sont
très très grande et vous voyez que sur
la face ventrale du coup la phase orale
il ya quasiment que de la zone en bus la
craie relais les zones il ya plus de
zones interrompu la craie sur la face au
rap parce que justement c'est où rien ne
bouge pas vraiment en fait ils
s'enterrent dans le sable et puis ils
filtrent le sable voilà il bouge
peut-être un peu mais j'en ai jamais vu
bouger donc je pense pas qu'il boude
si quelqu'un sait si les oursins
réguliers et irréguliers bouge
prière de vous le faire savoir dans les
commentaires et ses oursins irréguliers
sont beaucoup plus intéressant du point
de vue stratégique puisque ils
n'apparaissent que à partir du trias
donc ils n'apparaissent qu'à partir du
mésozoïque c'est au sain et régulier
donc si vous trouvez un oursin et
régulier vous savez déjà que vous n'êtes
pas en train de regarder des roches du
paléozoïque et s'ils sont et en plus
s'ils sont plats et bien là vous savez
que vous êtes carrément dans le cndd aux
os x parce que les oursins les oursins
irrégulier du mésozoïque conservent
globalement la forme de boule comme
celui-là il conserve une forme de boule
généralement plus une forme de coeur
d'ailleurs il ya des petits oursins en
france que vous trouvez sur les falaises
d'étretat qui sont en forme de coeur et
qui sont très très joli donc ça c'est ça
c'est au mésozoïque mais à partir du
cénozoïque du coup bah c ur sain et
régulier deviennent aussi plat donc
c'est ce que vous voyez là c'est les
dollars de mer par exemple sont sont des
oursins tout plat qui viennent
typiquement du cénozoïque donc si vous
avez un oursin tout plat typiquement
dans le milieu scène vous trouvé
beaucoup d'entre eux valeo raptor pourra
vous en parler
c'est des bons indicateurs du cénozoïque
donc ses oursins ils sont très très très
intéressant pour la biostratigraphie
donc les réguliers à partir du
paléozoïque du milieu du paléozoïque
voile à partir de l'ordovicien quoi les
réguliers à partir de l'ordovicien et
puis ensuite les irréguliers à partir du
séno eu lieu à partir du mésozoïque et
les tout plat à partir du cénozoïque et
les oursins ils sont aussi intéressants
parce qu'il raconte une histoire sympa
au niveau de la crise permien trias donc
au paléozoïque vous aviez des oursins en
fait qui avait un nombre très variable
de zone interdite la cre r ça pouvait
aller de 2 à 8 à 12
tout ce que vous voulez un nombre très
variable de zone inter en bus la crème
donc avec un grand nombre des pin
parfois les accompagnant et en fait il
ya qu une seule là qu'un seul genre
doursat irrégulier qui a survécu
à la limite permise trias s'est mis
aussi daris et il n'avait que deux zones
internes bula chrtr et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui on a des oursins qui ont
tous que deux ont interrompu la crème
parce que mieux si daris il a redonné
naissance après à tous les oursins
régulier d'aujourd'hui mais aussi aux
oursins et régulier que ce soit les
ronds du mésozoïque ou les plats du
cénozoïque il ya toujours des oursins
régulière ont aujourd'hui enfin
sphérique
aujourd'hui c'est juste que ceux qui
sont plats ne se retrouvent que
océanologique mais voilà donc c'est une
histoire plutôt intéressante on arrive à
avoir à suivre cette évolution en fait
de comment comment le nombre de régions
à terre en bus la créa a été
drastiquement réduit par la crise
permien trias donc la morphologie des
oursins d'aujourd'hui est directement
hérité d'une crise qui a eu lieu il y à
250 millions d'années et je trouve ça
carrément cool 250 millions d'années
c'est quand même un quart de milliard
d'années quoi c'est ça qui est ça qui
est super chouettes et les grappes
tollitte les grappes tollitte c'est des
trucs on sait pas ce que c'est
exactement mais ça ressemble à des dents
de scie voilà et ça et c'est essayer
intéressant que parce qu'on les retrouve
au paléozoïque et on n'a aucune idée de
comment ça vivait on imagine que c'était
des formes coloniale qui flottait dans
la flotte mais on ne sait pas vraiment
voilà et ceci signe la fin du cours sur
les invertébrés
je ne veux pas j'ai aucun problème
contre les grappes tollitte mais c'est
juste qu'on sait rien d'eux à part
qu'ils ressemblent à des à part que
c'est des microfossiles et qui ressemble
à des six à des petites mains qui
ressemblent à des petits machins avec
des dents de scie et qu'ils sont des
marqueurs du paléozoïque donc on les
utilise beaucoup en biostratigraphie du
paléozoïque mai mais voilà on sait rien
d'eux à part ça voilà donc avec ces
grappes tollitte voici la fin de notre
grande saga sur de notre grand de notre
grand feuilleton de l'été devrais je
dire les cours de paléontologie que je
donne à l'université du vibrateur sand
je vous remercie de les avoir suivis et
je vous dis à très bientôt pour la
rentrée ciao